das ist wirklich meine bei echten
überraschung ich konnte eigentlich gar
nicht zu glauben
[Musik]
willkommen beim ein video jahre hatte
ich hoffe euch gefällt
ich befinde mich gerade in unserer neuen
wohnung habe ich glaube ich auch schon
mal gesagt auf jeden fall haben jetzt
schon einen realen hintergrund
die wurden nimmt voran ist aber noch
längst nicht fertig die küche ist auch
immer noch nicht aufgebaut was ich will
eigentlich gar nicht eingeladen aber ich
muss dir nicht mit kurzem erzählt und
zwar kam er vor ungefähr zwei oder drei
wochen das video von mir die top 10
schönsten youtube und das ist echt ganz
gut angekommen und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht alex macht doch einfach noch im
ähnliches video
heute geht es nämlich um die top 10 der
unbeliebtesten youtuber and deutschland
ja ich bin halt jemand ich beschäftige
mich wirklich sehr dass wir mit welchem
zahlen irgendwelche statistiken da bin
ich irgendwie ganz gut und so was
interessiert mich einfach ich könnte
euch jetzt auch einfach die 101 vom ein
städten der welt als vielleicht nicht
alle städte der welt aber von vielen
aufzählen aber darum geht es auch nicht
als bin ja selber uns natürlich
unterwegs und schauen wir so andere
youtuber an und es gibt ja immer viel
hätte sie viel geredet und ich habe mich
hingesetzt und habe geschaut werden die
beliebtesten youtube sind die
unbeliebtesten youtube das habe ich als
ein bisschen berechnet mit einem
taschenrechner als heute gehts halt um
die unpolitischen youtuber deutschland
oder als deutschland also im
deutschsprachigen raum ist das ganze
habe ich folgendermaßen gemacht ich habe
immer die letzte nacht aufgesucht und
hab dann dort die like des gleich
verhältnisse ausgerechnet im prozent
also wie viel prozent von den letzten
acht den dislike oder wurden halt die
letzten acht videos gewiss leicht von
diesem youtube und dann ein ranking
erstellt und das habe ich jetzt fertig
und möchten euch gerne präsentieren weiß
nicht interessiert und ich glaube viele
von euch draußen auch natürlich kann man
ist das schon ein gewisser weise denken
wir jetzt da drin ist und er nicht und
ich auch auf jeden fall noch sagen muss
also natürlich kann es sein dass ich
irgendwann vergessen hab jetzt sagen
würde
der muss auch in das ranking aber ich
habe auch wirklich zu sämtliche etwas
kleinere youtuber die dann
und haben dann tod gerettet werden
rausgelassen einfach aus dem wurden weil
es da so viele von geben würde und
deswegen gibt es nur etwas größer
youtube die die meisten von euch
eventuell kennen sollten nur das wasser
auch wirklich verstanden wird vielleicht
mal für diejenigen die es interessiert
ich habe das gleich auch in meinen
letzten videos gemacht und winter auf
einen durchschnittswert von drei prozent
bekommen das heißt alle bewertungen von
meiner letzten acht videos waren zu drei
prozent halt des lacks was eigentlich
echt in akzeptabler wert ist glaube ich
also jeder 97 gib mir halten ist
eigentlich voll okay wird man mit dem
zehnten platz und den zehnten platz
belegen
also wie gesagt das ist ein sehr
aktuelles ranking es bezieht sich nur
auf die letzten acht
und ich glaube wenn man jetzt die ganzen
feld frank von dem frank gross zu der
ganzen sache hinzufügt denn sie das
schon wieder ganz anders aus denn wenn
die viel weiter oben weil ich auf die
uhr geld deswegen haben jetzt glaube ich
alles offline genommen keine ahnung auf
jeden fall wirkt sich das auf diese
videos die sie jetzt machen und dort
sind sieben prozent aller bewertungen
des leicht was echt noch voll okay ist
als 7 prozent
das wird noch schlimmer wäre es so
einfach drunter seinen das ju und zwar
eine die zweite von acht prozent was
eigentlich auch kein großer wert meint
das ist ein bisschen über mir aber auch
nicht viel
also ich hätte wirklich eindeutig
gedacht faymann west über viel weiter
oben in dem ranking ist aber nicht warum
auch immer
brauche ich dazu auch eigentlich gar
nicht sagen damit ihr das jetzt auch
nicht falsch versteht von den ganzen
youtuber das sind natürlich auch alles
welche die ziemlich beliebt sind sie
sind ja ziemlich populär polarisieren
viel viele leute kennen sie aber es ging
letztlich um diesen beliebtheitsgrad
sondern um diese dislike rate seit
michaels viel mehr interessiert wir
wachsen weiter mit der nächsten youtube
ist eigentlich nicht überraschend und
zwar ist das bietet die pelle
mit 9% ich sag mal so die macht ungefähr
auf ein video 150000 like von den werten
von 15.000 bis leicht dabei auf jedem
video super sagen ich hab so im
durchschnitt auf jedem video 15.000
likes vielleicht 20.000 keine ahnung
und biel macht das einfach eiskalt als
disler expected auf jeden fall schon
krass wenn man sich das mal so vor
aufführt ok vorsprung der nächste platz
13 prozent bis 2 grad in der letzten
videos geht dann hätte ich eigentlich
gar nicht mal so unbedingt gedacht also
deutschland überraschend für mich aber
gut 13 prozent sind jetzt auch nicht die
welt
wir warten mal ab was da noch so kommt
der nächste plötzlich doch mit 25 oder
so das ist wirklich meine einem echten
überraschung
ich konnte eigentlich gar nicht zu
glauben aber an sich gibt halt immer
mehr menschen die so content einfach
akzeptieren ich akzeptieren auch völlig
natürlich ist das eine oder andere auch
vielleicht mal ein bisschen übertrieben
und ein bisschen sehr provokant
dargestellt und müsste jetzt nicht
unbedingt auf youtube hochgeladen werden
aber 15 prozent die straße hat katja
krawiec ich glaube die war vor einem
jahr jedoch kompliziert sich prozent
oder sonstwer freut mich sehr für sie
ich meine sie hat ihr ding durchgezogen
und es funktioniert ja und 15 prozent
ist eigentlich echt nicht viel für sein
konnten kommen wir zum ersten platz
und der geht an ich glaube so vor einem
halben jahr lag der eindeutig mit
absolut auf platz 1 aber es hat sich
auch geändert weil da kann jemand der
dachte sich das kannste nicht
akzeptieren
du musst auf platz 1 der meisten bis
leicht und der komplett gleich also bei
upgrade die folgendermaßen aus bis zehn
prozent aller bewertungen den dislike
was für ihn eigentlich eine echte
steigerung ist ich glaube so vor einem
halben jahr wartezeit auf 240 oder halt
auch mal 80 prozent kontakt ganz oft gut
aber ich meine wenn jetzt jeder 506 das
video am stammsitz leicht welche die
person die davon so betroffen das ist
natürlich ein bisschen schade und schon
relativ viel aber es gehört dazu dass
man zu platz zwei und der geht an
ich würde sagen er hat sich auf jeden
fall auch gesteigert aber platz zwei ist
michael pawlu mit unfassbaren oder was
ist unfassbar aber es sind halt 19 fast
20 prozent jeder fünfte des videos ist
eigentlich schon schade ich muss ehrlich
sagen so die letzten videos fand ich
ganz amüsant glück mir jetzt auch nicht
jedes wieder von ihm an aber
irgendwann mal ein video gesehen von der
woche oder so das fand ich eigentlich
ganz gut und die displays sind dann halt
irgendwie da verständlich nicht
unbedingt aber hat sich halt irgendwie
so eingepegelt ich bin mal gespannt was
wir hier unter diesem video fünf
verhältnis haben schaffen wir 10.000
likes und 100 dislike dann hätten wir
ein prozent ungefähr 0,9 prozent wenn
ihr denkt bestimmt gerade von mir ich
kann so folgen rechnen
ich habe im ersten semester von meinem
studium alles bestand aus hatte hatte
habe ich 50 also ein richtiges mathe
genie bin ich dann halt auch wie das wir
uns alle mal kräftig luft denn jetzt
kommt platz 1
vielleicht könnte es auch viele von euch
sich schon denken ich meinte man
wirklich scheiße hochlädt dann muss man
sich darüber nicht beschweren da kann
man sich nicht über beschwerden
denn beschwerden kann man sich da auf
jeden fall eher weniger der erste platz
geht an den einzigartigen lehrern mache
ich bin leonberg der anmarsch
guck mal wie ich jetzt im club deine
marsch er ja ich glaube dieser vertrag
schon einige filme aus bei leon die
folgendermaßen aus 24 prozent aller
bewertungen sind bis leicht also jeder
vierte dislike leons videos und damit
befindet er sich aktuell auf platz eins
dazwischen glückwunsch
kann ich dir irgendwas dazu dem
krisentief okay leute sucht jetzt
verrate ich hoffe dass sie dadurch
gefallen hat auf jeden fall nach oben
akzeptiert und instagram und wir sehen
uns dann eventuell schon morgen wieder
morgen gibt's neues video im krieg auch
am mittleren dass spanien ich freue mich
mega groß also seid gespannt in spanien
folgenden tag coole videos
wir sind rein